Casey Spivey yeah Wow amazing
good job what's your name mean it's
brave and I don't know what a cool name
Thanks
believes any more fires Hotel I'm Greg
although that's my name this is Casey
Spivey brave Spivey over here you could
catch Casey over at Screen Rant that's
where I found her and you could catch
her on Instagram and Twitter at hey
underscore case you've heard of a
director named Wesley Anderson right
yeah is his name Wesley or left I go I
call him Wesley because related all I
know about it is he's directed it and I
think he wrote it let's not read
anything else on it let's go whoa
Asian letters great japanese
archipelago' yeah whoa epidemic
proportions rips through the city of
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so intimately I love it I love it
why should because he's dogs like this
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive to find your dog
Wow
there's some really language
[Laughter]
the north a long rickety causeway over
not just sledge marks lead to a
radioactive landfill I toxic chemical
garbage that's our destination it's an
order Bill Murray Jeff Goldblum what
he's got like actual Japanese actors in
there or like two or three Yoko Ono yeah
sure no yeah great Scarlett Johansson
the Japanese actress engrossed in the
show
sue I did there do you think those
things were 3d printed good question
like okay 3d print okay so 3d printing
is like you design it on the computer
and then you literally print it out and
it's printed it prints like a mold like
out of whatever claymation yeah it's
like yeah exactly
looks like claymation Yeah right so I
think the faces on the human look like
3d printed thanks like the dogs look
claymation yeah but the humans look a
little different yeah yeah I think
they've 3d printed their stuff I mean
it's probably a hybrid of both how
excited for night it looks great beyond
the animation though I love I love this
storytelling I haven't seen fantastic
mr. Fox yet okay have you seen it I saw
it on an airplane that is the same
experience gotcha
what tangley have I saw moonrise kingdom
yes I was thinking like this guy has
kind of a cartoon like a surreal cartoon
of remakes great film yeah I haven't
even seen the trailer for fantastic mr.
Fox so seeing this trailer for like his
type of animated movie I'm well yeah is
this is directed exactly like a Wes
Anderson movie but it's an animation I
prefer this I think his style might work
a little better I appreciate
how he does the movies but I find them a
little like stiff little stiff they're a
little dark quirky for me first they
have to be in a mood to watch a Wes
Anderson as opposed to just let's turn
on and have a good time you know
all right let's BRT first yeah I think
it's a really well composed training
yeah
the first barmy it's funny the
introduces a world yeah great set up
characters and then the adventure and
then in funky a lot of humor then
intensity yeah it's got everything I'm
like this seems like a full film right
here and there's about dogs and what a
cool story of like wanting to get your
dog yeah yeah give a dog my roommate has
a dog so yes I do I'm an ass right don't
ever break up with that she's my own oh
that's cute
I love doggies my sister has a dog and I
gave her I have a heart yeah the cast of
actors to me are just amazing that you
got her for the American people I know
Liev Schreiber in there Liev Schreiber
that's the go-to name your eyes
immediately gonna go to I see the huge
list of actors I mean ed Norton Bill
Murray have worked with him before
I don't know if Brian Cranston has but
Bryan Cranston has the best voice yeah
like it is perfect for an animation or a
live-action film voiceover oh except
when I do that Oh cuz I have a manly
voice and then I go oh oh thanks I
appreciate the compliment that is me
that's how I receive conscious about how
I'm talking don't be because I
compliment okay how're you doing video
let's just say yes you go you rank in is
I'm assuming he's some famous guy from
Oh female oh it's a little boy this
thing you know wishes hold the mic up
here I thought he was born in 2017 I was
like wait a second
he's this who's working with Sanderson
he's not even American Jeff go but
there's a lot of great actors who would
provide wonderful voices for it here
Courtney B Vance man and it seems like I
don't know I take it that Wes Anderson
might have like a side passion for like
Japanese material because it's
translating here yeah but it's not
stereotypical yeah it doesn't look like
a white guy making fun of it yeah it's
not oh yeah it looks like it's honoring
its own style it looks like a Wes
Anderson Japanese movie yeah this looks
fantastic I rarely get excited for a Wes
Anderson film I'm genuinely excited to
see that looks very cute heartwarming oh
yay oh yeah no yeah Wesley my best
friend Wesley Wesley hey guys you know
you can do with your life you can
subscribe to the real rejects it might
be worth it click that notification bill
to get notified whenever videos out you
got to subscribe and a notification
about and then take down my phone number
and get me here call and I'll tell you
how to do the rest the brodster
patreon become a pig trying to check
today hey case hey underscore case on
Instagram Twitter follow her there one
of the many great people over at Screen
Rant she's an awesome host that's how I
found her discover her talent and said
you want to go bigger than the screen
rants come on the real rejects